hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the magnus carlson chester yes
i'm back home and hope everything is
finally okay with the audio now
uh we are starting off uh the video with
the armageddon game
as i've been traveling and i didn't get
a chance to
cover all the games but i will get back
to some of the nicer ones uh tomorrow
however i will mention what happened so
far
so this is the armageddon but before
that of course we had four rapid games
and two blitz games
in the rapid games first magnus took the
lead and then hikaru retaliated in game
three
uh so of course game four ended in a
draw they went into the blitz section
and then he car won game one in the
blitz magnus uh gave up a pawn he wanted
to
uh to try and hold the draw with
opposite colored bishops
being upon down but hikaru was able to
win that and then
magnus was able to win on demand in game
six that's the second game of the blitz
forcing armageddon and now we have the
armageddon game
uh crazy stuff uh where magnus chose
black uh magnus always gets to choose uh
uh what uh what color he wants in
armageddon
as he qualified for the grand final by
winning one of the previous events
so that being said uh let's check it out
so hikaru with the white pieces
needs to win this game uh it's
armageddon uh five minutes for hikaru on
the clock and four minutes for magnus he
opens with e4
sorry about that and will we again see
the berlin defense we have e5 by magnus
we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 so the
real lopez is on the board and yes of
course we will
the berlin defense knight to f6 by
magnus
uh we have d3 by hikaru and bishop to c5
and now this trade we've seen this
plenty of times in
their clashes during the past few days
the captures on c6 and knight b
to d2 maybe the knight coming to c4
going after the e5 pawn with bishop to
e6 and now
h3 preparing a different line we have
knight to d7 now preparing f6
to strengthen the e5 pawn and knight to
f1 now the pawn is coming to g4 and this
knight
will be coming to g3 so f6 by magnus
strengthens this pawn and now there is
one game in the database where bishop
e3 was played but here we have the
instant the g4 by hikaru
which is a new move so already as of
move nine we have a completely new game
uh queen e7 by magnus as those pawns are
already
far advanced you don't want to probably
castle kingside so magnus
russia's queen side first knight g3 now
of course
and then we have queen side castles by
magnus queen to e2
hikaru also plans to play bishop to e3
and castle queenside
king to b8 by magnus and now a3 so
uh nakamura needs to stir something up
and magnus just needs to keep everything
in
in order uh to not gamble too much as
a draw is the same as a win for him in
this game
bishop backed the b6 and now bishop to
e3 he car
needs to continue developing the castle
we have knight the f8 shifting the
knight over to
uh to g6 uh then it's possible for the
knight at some points to come to h4
we have castles by hikaru and now knight
the g6
uh with knight sorry knight stage f5
putting pressure
uh on the g7 pawn if the queen moves
it's going to be a liability
so here bishop captures an e3 uh queen
captures magnus trades off one of the
bishops and now pushes c5 so
gaining complete control over the d4
square and
uh if necessary at any point magnus can
go c4 to create some sort of a
breakthrough in the center
so knight d2 by hikaru shifting the
knight over to the queen side
and now b6 just uh giving that c5 pawn
additional protection
weakening the light squares somewhat uh
but uh
magnus still has a light square bishop
so it's not a problem you can just shift
it
over there if needed knight to b1 by
hikaru preparing knight to c3
from there you can go to to b5 to to d5
if needed to a4 also
we have knights to h for by magnus now
preparing to push the pawn to g5 create
a
sort of a safe haven on f4 for this
knight and then shift the knight back
knight to g6 and then to f4 it will be
an excellent square for the knight
and also uh by this maneuver you will
finally deal with hikaru's pesky knight
on h5
so rook h the g1 by hikaru and now
g5s plan not allowing any pushes like g5
or f4
uh we have knight to c3 finally bringing
that knight into the game
and now knight back to g6 now the knight
is coming to f4 as it is an excellent
outpost for the knight
uh we have king to b1 by hikaru a nice
prophylactic move
as always and now knight to f4 and now
this is a this is a beautiful knight
uh you don't want it there like at all
so you you need to capture this so
knight captures
g captures my magnus doubles his pawn
but it's not a problem as it comes with
tempo and also
h5 is coming so here we have queen to e2
and now h5 by magnus
he wants to do captures captures and
then double up his rooks on the h
file to trade off the rooks and then
ensure that he has a very very simple
game to play
so f3 hikaru strengthens the g4 pawn we
have captures captures as planned and
now
rook to h3 now putting pressure on the
f3 pawn and also preparing the doubling
of the rooks on the h file
rook to g2 by hikaru and now rook d to
h8
uh we have rook d to g1 doubling up on
the g file of course hikaru now wants to
make a breakthrough with the g5
so rook the h1 by magnus now magnus can
just trade off one of the rooks at will
and here he carl plays b3 and this
allows magnus a very very sneaky idea
here magnus pushes c4 he sacrifices upon
well not really sacrifices upon because
he's gonna grab the a3 pawn but he will
mess up white's pawn structure in the
center here
so d captures on c4 by hikaru we have
queen captures on a3
and now finally g5 here magnus trades
you could also capture and then trade
but magnus prefers to
just trade a rook captures on g5 and now
a5 if the knight moves then a4 could be
very strong busting open the white
king's position
uh if knight to b5 just going after the
queen now the problem queen c5 just puts
pressure on the rook on g1
not much here for white so queen to d3
and now
king to b7 uh and uh hikaru is much
better on time and remember
uh there is no increment in armageddon
if uh and anyone flags anyone then the
game's over
so rook the g7 are now gaining control
of the
of the seventh rank but now magnus
doesn't like this he was waiting for
this and only now does he trade rook so
captures captures
and rook to h7 preventing any harm from
you know strolling through the
through the seventh rank so knight to a4
he car now prepares c5 could be an idea
if punk
uh well if c5 lets upon captures queen
b5 check might be interesting
however we have queen to d6 immediately
magnus offers a queen trade
uh and now of course hikaru uh if he car
trades this is very comfortable for
black to hold magnus very
uh well very confident that he will be
able to hold this
so instead after this queen to d6 he
carl moves the queen queen to c3
uh i was watching this game live uh with
with the elena and elena mentioned
that hikaru should play queen to c3 here
which he did
and now let's say rook to g5 going after
the e5 pawn
could be possible but bishop to d7
magnus stops this in a very tricky idea
now if you try something like this
then allowing this rook to go for h1
will be a bit too dangerous let's say
bishop captures captures
and now this is never a problem because
rook the h1
check king a2 and now queen d7 let's say
goes after this pawn if queen here
then queen here threatens checkmate and
if you block this then just look here
and there is no more
not not much you can do here if king
blocks the defender is just queen
captures you create a pass pawn
white just falls apart here so hikaru
must retreat with the knight knight to
b2
and then now comes rook to h3 again
putting pressure on the h3 pawn rook to
d1 pushing
magnus's queen back queen e7 and now
knight to d3
a really interesting move by hikaru
because here hikaru says if you capture
i'm just going to play knight to c5
check and your rook will be under attack
but this is exactly what magnus does he
plays a rook captures on f3
and what's the point here well the point
is if knight to c5 check
then magnus captures with the queen it's
not a problem uh because uh
now after queen captures on f3 he's
gonna play bishop to c6 and
black is up upon here white has a double
c pawn
and even though he carl would be up the
exchange here magnus says you're not
breaking through this my light square
bishop will take care of the light
squares here
so you will not get many chances to
attack the the pawns which are on dark
squares
uh this pawn is very weak i'm going to
play this bust open the the king's
position
and uh well i will hold this very easily
so here after luke captures on f3 magnus
uh he car played
queen captures on e5 offers a queen
trade
but now uh something very interesting
happens as it usually does when we reach
the position from the thumbnail
feel free to pause the video here and
find a
an idea that magnus played while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on maybe not finding
the absolute best move but
for the armageddon where draw is enough
it is definitely the best move here
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show magnus played
rook captures on d3 and he sacrificed
the queen
well gave up the queen for a knight and
the rook uh here hikaru has nothing
better he has to accept the queen trade
another queen trade he has to accept the
queen rook captures on d1 with check
king to b2
and now bishop to c6 and now uh each
player has a pass pawn however
it's going to be very very interesting
so e5
hikaru starts pushing his pass pawn and
magnus does the same
f3 we have queen to f6 and now rook to
d2
uh say uh preparing the push of the pawn
to f2
e6 and now f2 and hikaru pushes the pawn
to e7
now with ideas of maybe a queen captures
bishop uh with check
king captures and promoting the pawn to
a queen so you have to uh you know be
ready for this so rook to e2
a magnus prevents against this tactic
now this does absolutely nothing
so here queen to f7 and now a very easy
way to
to handle things for magnus just rook
captures on e7
and here if you capture uh i mean
there's nothing better
yeah if you capture uh then just uh
pawn to f1 gets a queen into the game so
here hikaru of course has the capture on
f2
but now rook g7 and now is this a
fortress or is this not a fortress
there's always a saying from magnus that
magnus doesn't believe in fortresses but
maybe he he believes in one work where
when he really needs want
to win the entire event so we'll see
what happens queen f4 and now rook the
g2
and of course it's not just if this is a
fortress or not but it's also
whether hikaru can flag magnus or not uh
so queen to e5 and rook to g6 and he
carl was some minute and 40 on the clock
i believe here in magnus around minute
and 10 seconds
uh maybe not exactly those times but uh
hikar was
somewhat up on time so rook back to g6
and now
c3 hikaru needs to create some chances
so he must
push the pawns rook g2 check king to c1
rook to g4 magnus just shifting between
the the
this square and the one guarded by the
bishop so he doesn't have to think too
much and waste time
we have queen e6 hoping that magnus
blunders the rook as
it does tend to happen in armageddon
rook to e4
challenging the queen queen f7 and now
rook to e1 check king d2
challenging the rook and now rook to e4
we have b4
and now uh a captures on b4 grabbing
that pawn
c captures and now b5 the queen protects
the pawn so of course you cannot capture
it
b5 and now you cannot push the pawn
because the b4 pawn hangs so here uh
hikaru trades we have c
captures uh bishop captures and queen to
d5
check almost winning the rook but not
quite as bishop
c6 just uh blocks check and defends the
rook
queen to c5 and now rook to e6 here we
have king to c3 he car
starts bringing the king into the game
and now rook to d6
uh we have b5 and now bishop to d7
preparing bishop to c8 and here
uh the fortress seems to be created as
now the king guards the bishop the
bishop will come to c8
the king will guard the bishop and the
pawn uh prevents
anything from reaching b6 or d6 and
carlson's plan is now
it doesn't matter how fast you are
you're not flagging me i'm just going to
move the rook rook b6 rook d6 rugby 6
rook d6
and even if magnus just pre-moves these
moves it's impossible for white to win
uh well almost impossible so queen to e5
and now bishop to c8 we have king to c4
and now rook back to b6 we have king to
c5
but now king b8 we have queen to e8 and
again
rook to d6 we have queen to f8 now
trying something just to gain time but
here magnus just played rook to b6 and
hikaru went into a deep thing he went to
lower
with time even than magnus had uh he
started laughing and it was
in this position that the players agreed
to a draw and
with this draw magnus carlsen is the
winner of the match uh and by that he
wins the match against icarl
four to three so really really intense
match uh
they were you know uh trading blow for
blow and uh in the end
magnus prevailed but it was uh it was
incredible
like hikaru had everything he won the
first blitz game he just needed a
drawing the second one then magnus
one out of nowhere and then magnus just
uh chose black
and it's very hard when you when you're
so close to the victory you know
uh magnus wins and then you're forced to
play armageddon and then magnus chooses
black and says okay now you have to beat
me with white
definitely not a pleasant position to be
in but
uh indian someone someone has to win and
this time it was magnus who wins
the entire magnus cross in chess tour he
wins the first prize uh
uh i believe sixty thousand dollars just
for just for this tournament
or maybe more maybe the difference
between the first place and second place
is sixty thousand dollars i'm not sure
we'll have to check that uh but it's
either 60 or 100 000 dollars
something along those lines uh but yeah
really incredible stuff uh sorry i
didn't manage to to upload the other
games as i was returning home from my
for my vacation
but i will tend to them tomorrow so if
you have any favorites do
use hashtag suggestion in the comments i
would like to thank
alvarado michael van melkenbeck
uh daniel duranka christopher paran and
tom hayden
hitler dwight for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing
uh the games we haven't covered from the
magnus cross and chester checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
and of course continuing the morphe saga
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day